as Bernie Sanders racks up victories all
around the country conservatives
struggle with whether to root for the
radical socialist so Trump can sweep all
57 States plus Greenland in November or
whether it would be better to root for
one of the also-rans on the off-chance
Bernie could somehow win we will examine
the conservative case for Bernie then
Pete Buddha judge has a prepubescent boy
come out as homosexual on stage in a
campaign rally AOC likes luxury for
herself but not for anyone else and so
much more I'm Michael Knowles and this
is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
Bernie wins Nevada are you feeling the
Bern we will figure out if we should
feel the Bern by the way we're gonna add
a new feature for the people watching
and the Daily wire app or the daily wire
website while you're watching if
anything occurs to you some brilliant
thought some pressing question feel free
to write that in and we'll try to get to
it live on the show because there's a
lot that happened over the last few days
namely the socialist revolution sweeping
Nevada with 88 percent of precincts
reporting 88 percent by the way that
Nevada caucus happened days ago but
because of this chaos in the caucus
system we still only have 88 percent
still 88 percent reporting bernie is
crushing it he definitely won Nevada
Bernie got forty seven point one percent
of the popular vote there for comparison
Joe Biden got less than half of that at
21 percent Budaj edge got thirteen point
seven percent Liz Warren got a pathetic
nine point six percent and then
everybody else followed afterward that
means that in the way the delegates
break down Bernie got 13 delegates Joe
Biden got two delegates Budaj got one
and folk acontece got zero nobody else
got anything worth pointing out to Mike
Bloomberg was not in the Nevada caucuses
he also won't be in South Carolina and
then he expects to sweep the Democratic
nomination on Super Tuesday when you
have a bunch of different states voting
we'll see how that goes Joe Biden came
in second place right but he still only
got two delegates this should have been
a pretty good state for him it didn't
play out that way Joe Biden has been
saying that South Carolina is going to
be his firewall so South Carolina's
happening next week on the 29th he's
he's lost he's lost his massive lead
okay he was he was crushing it in South
Carolina according to the Real Clear
Politics average which is sort of the
average of all the top polls Joe Biden
is now at twenty four point five percent
in South Carolina
Bernie's at 21.5 percent they're running
neck-and-neck in South Carolina South
Carolina
Joe Biden was supposed to run away with
that state Bernie wasn't supposed to be
anywhere near him
last October Joe Biden was at 38.3% in
South Carolina Bernie was at nine point
seven percent so Joe Biden had a 4x lead
on Bernie Sanders there and yet after
Iowa after New Hampshire after Nevada
all of a sudden that lead has completely
disappeared
Bernie's running second and really
they're running neck-and-neck this shows
you an important rule in politics it's a
rule that I I don't know that I've seen
it violated in presidential politics and
yet people always forget it you don't
win by losing the left and the right
forget this rule all the time okay we
see evidence of this repeatedly no one
learns the lesson Rudy Giuliani tried
this 2008 Rudy Giuliani was running for
president but he decided he wasn't gonna
win Iowa I wasn't gonna win New
Hampshire wasn't gonna win Seth but he's
gonna win Florida so we're gonna lose
all the first states but then Rudy's
gonna come out of nowhere and magically
win Florida that did not happen Mike
Bloomberg same thing Mike Bloomberg now
is saying okay I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna even be in Iowa or New Hampshire
or Nevada or South Carolina but then the
big states come along and unmagical e
gonna win it and Bloomberg has
incinerated well over half a billion
dollars at this point still unlikely
that that happens never Trump made this
argument never Trump made the argument
in 2016 that conservatives should not
vote for Donald Trump because it would
be better if Hillary won and then you
know some bad things happened but then
don't worry cuz four years later we're
gonna come back better than ever but
that wouldn't have happened the
incumbent always has an advantage in
reelection and politics is based on
momentum it's not based on okay we're
gonna strategically lose and then you
guys are gonna win and get a bunch of
victories for the next few years but
really by losing we're secretly winning
because that way next time we're gonna
come back and we're gonna clobber you
you can't predict that that's not how it
works
and by the way the you know the people
who make these bets
Rudy Guiliani Joe Biden they're not very
good at predicting the next six months
forget about the next six years or so so
Bernie Sanders right now has absolutely
no business polling as well as he does
and yet he's almost at the top of the
charts South Carolina is relatively
conservative and heavily black in terms
of the voting demographics bernie is a
northeast socialist who had about two
black supporters until the day before
yesterday right that was Joe Biden's
whole case when you really boil down Joe
Biden's case for his nomination to its
crassest level his case was I can get
black voters and no one else can in this
race right now and yet all of a sudden
Bernie starts to do that why why is
Bernie starting to pick up these this
diverse coalition it's because people
like to pick a winner and Bernie right
now is winning so the delegate count for
everything Iowa New Hampshire Nevada
right now it stands that Bernie Sanders
34 Budaj 23 Joe Biden eight Liz Warren
eight Club you charge seven so right now
Biden who was the front-runner is more
or less tied with Liz Warren and Amy
Klobuchar that's how badly he's doing in
a big question that comes up for
conservatives given all of that given
the fact that Bernie right now is
running away with the nomination should
conservatives feel the Bern we will get
to that because there's some major
debate going on but I have strong
feelings about it first I got to thank
our friends over at fairway
meat market I it has now been about 12
hours since I last ate fairway meat
market because it is so so delicious
that I had to have it for dinner last
night fairway is a family-owned grocery
chain that has been in business since
1938 fairways premium beef and
all-natural pork is raised by family
farmers and hand-cut by a highly
experienced team of fairway butchers
from ribs to rib eyes pork chops to beef
tenderloin you get it all at fairway
meat market calm I had the pork chops
last night these pork chops are superb
very often now you go to the local
grocery store the pork chops aren't that
good they're kind of thin you don't get
them on the bone
this beautiful thick on the bone
absolutely fabulous how would you like
to get a deal on fairways heartland
package that includes eight 8-ounce all
natural boneless pork chops six eight
ounce USDA choice ribeye steaks one
mouth-watering side dish which could be
loaded baked potato or load of potato
baked rather gourmet cheesy corn or
brisket baked beans this week my
listeners can get the heartland package
which is valued at 230 bucks for just
$99.99 plus free shipping when you enter
Knolls at checkout dana wles 50% off the
best meat in america plus free shipping
fairway meat market compro moto knowles
look for the heartland package should
conservatives feel the Bern yes yes we
should burn baby burn
Democratic inferno this brings up a
difference of opinion some conservatives
say that we should back Bernie because
he's a 200 year old insane socialist and
Trump is going to win every single state
if he gets the nomination the other side
of this is because some conservatives
say we shouldn't back Bernie because
anything can happen the fact that Donald
Trump got elected president tells you
anything can happen in politics and if
somehow Bernie became president that
would be so devastating and horrible for
the country we can't even risk it it
would be better for the Democrats to
nominate a candidate who is more likely
to beat Trump than for them to nominate
Bernie Sanders I think that is not very
sound reasoning I think we got to feel
the Bern why I am afraid of Bernie's
popular support unlike Mike Bloomberg or
Hillary Clinton or John Kerry or Al Gore
Bernie actually does have popular
support there like real people who show
up to his rallies however his support is
different from Trump's support Trump
also had popular support that's why some
conservatives now are a little nervous
about Bernie in 2016
Trump supporters were not hardcore
ideologues so Bert Trump supporters in
2016 I would say were your kind of
run-of-the-mill conservative
people maybe they wouldn't even describe
themselves as conservative with a
capital C they just love their country
they want better trade deals they feel
they've been cheated by definitely by
the left and really by both parties and
they like that he fights back and they
like that he talks straight and they
voted for they like that he's strong the
the hardcore ideologue in in 2016 who
were conservative like Ted Cruz or they
liked Rand Paul they liked people with
these fully fleshed out coherent views
of the world that were based on years
and years of research and reading right
that's where the the hardline ideologue
went that wasn't Trump Bernie's
supporters are the hardcore ideologues
okay Bernie supporters are actual
socialists the people working for his
campaign talk about how they've got
gulags and they're gonna line up the
neoliberals and put them in front of a
firing squad if Bernie gets elected
those are real quotes that you can see
on video there aren't that many hardcore
socialist ideologues in America there
there are too many for us to feel
comfortable there more than we'd like
there to be but there aren't all that
many so when you look at just a base of
support bernie is base is much narrower
much more off-putting much less in line
with the american tradition than trump's
base of support the other difference is
that in 2016
Trump came out of nowhere okay nobody
took him seriously nobody thought he was
gonna get the nomination he was a silly
sideshow right so the the Democrats and
the Republican primary candidates they
were preparing their Oppo files on Ted
Cruz on Marco Rubio on Jeb Bush on all
of the candidates that were more in the
normal line right so when Trump got the
nomination they were just they didn't
know what to do they didn't have a lot
of good Appa they got some video clips
they got the Access Hollywood tape but
we all knew about those kinds of things
right they didn't show us anything we
didn't know oh yeah Trump makes comments
about women well he's been doing that in
the public eye for 40 years
right they didn't get any good stuff
they didn't get any private business
scandals they actually had to get the
federal
government to spy in the Trump campaign
and they still came up empty-handed
so Trump comes that in nowhere he wins
the nomination Bernie doesn't come out
of nowhere
Bernie comes from fifty years in
politics so the Oppo file on Bernie
Sanders is massive okay Bernie is very
well known among political nerds right
but he's not known like an international
celebrity and reality TV star and real
estate mogul and guy who's been in the
press for forty years okay he's been in
politics he's been in government mostly
obscure getting nothing done now the
Trump team knows about Bernie okay the
Bernie was the big threat in 2016
Bernie almost got the nomination in 2016
so the Trump team has been building that
Oppo file in a way that the Democrats
were not doing that on Trump going into
2016 and Bernie keeps making new fodder
for that Oppo file so he was on 60
minutes last night doubling down in his
support of Fidel Castro I want to get to
that in a second first a question just
came in from the live chat from Jay s
question is is Bernie's campaign just
run on Envy yes it is that's the way to
put it Winston Churchill said that
socialism is the gospel of envy and the
creed of ignorance that's all it is and
what the left manages to do because the
left always flips everything exactly
backwards is they've managed to convince
you that envy is a virtue it's the same
way that they now celebrate pride pride
is the deadliest of the seven deadly
sins right it's the it goes before
destruction and a haughty spirit before
a fall
pride is like it cause Satan to fall
from heaven it's like the worst thing
you can possibly have and yet they've
made pride into the greatest virtue and
they celebrate it for a whole month it's
the same thing with envy they've
convinced you that if you work hard and
or satisfied with what you have and are
selfless and charitable that you're a
sucker you're an idiot you're a dupe
you're actually sort of evil if you
advocate that kinds of system but if you
covet other people's goods and you want
to steal all their money in and property
somehow you're generous and charitable
right it's it's backwards it's
hiren but as sweet little Lisa pointed
out when we were discussing whether
Bernie Sanders we should feel the Bern
or not feel the Bern she said you know
Mac people do like free stuff people do
like free stuff you know that is that is
the fear of the trot of the Sanders
campaign he's really tapping into that
but I think people will still see
through it because he keeps making such
huge mistakes like last night when he
doubled down on his support of Fidel
Castro we'll get to that in a second
first I got to thank our friends over at
Rock Auto you know how much I love Rock
Auto it is a family-run business okay
and they have reliably low prices and
most importantly for somebody like me
they make it so simple to sort through
all these auto parts for your car for
the right make and model that even I can
do it on their website chain stores have
different price tiers for professional
mechanics and for you rockauto.com
doesn't even require membership or an
account login it's just always there
they have been helping people get Auto
Parts online for 20 years which is
pretty much the entire history of the
Internet why would you spend up to twice
as much for the same parts that's what
happens when people go to the regular
brick-and-mortar store or then really
what the brick-and-mortar does you go
and you say I need this part and they
come back and they say okay we're gonna
order it in for you when we're just
gonna charge you a lot more don't do
that go right to rockauto.com they've
got everything that you need go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck then
right in Knolls
in 2d how did you hear about us box and
you will let them know that we sent you
that's rockauto.com right in Noel's
Bernie Sanders is on 60 minutes with
Anderson Cooper and Anderson Cooper to
his credit brings up this question from
Bernie's 20 30 40 years ago he's been
saying the same thing for a long time he
defends these communist thugs
these dictators who slaughter their own
people including Fidel Castro and he
says hey Bernie you probably want to
take back some of your support for Fidel
Castro don't you what does Bernie do he
absolutely doubles down on it back in
the 1980s Sanders had some positive
things to say about the former Soviet
Union and the Sandinistas in Nicaragua
and everybody was totally convinced Irie
is explaining why the Cuban people
didn't rise up and help the u.s.
overthrow
Cuban leader Fidel Castro he educated
the kids gave them health care totally
transformed the society were very
opposed to the authoritarian nature of
Cuba but you know you got it's unfair to
simply say everything is bad you know
when Fidel Castro came into office you
know what he did he had a massive
literacy program is that a bad thing
even though Fidel Castro did he a lot of
dissidents in prison didn't that's right
and we condemned that yeah yeah we can
done that but you know look if Castro
you can't say Castro so bad what you're
telling me Stalin was that bad he was he
never did any good thing in his whole
life come on he kissed his mother one
time come on he's not a he's a good guy
as usual Bernie Sanders is completely
misrepresenting history here but this is
one of these lines that that communists
useful idiots would you have be used
since the 60s and certainly since the
80s when Bernie was doing they say well
when Fidel Castro took over he
instituted a literacy program sort of
not really when Fidel Castro took over
Cuba had a very high literacy rate the
image they want to present is that the
Cuban people were totally ignorant
didn't know how to read completely and
that's why they were oppressed and then
this man of the people Fidel Castro
comes in and teaches them to read that's
not what happened as early as the 1950s
well before Fidel Castro got into power
Cuba had a relatively high literacy rate
was about 80% then Fidel Castro comes in
any Institute's a literacy program but
it wasn't to teach people to read
relative the region everybody already
knew how to read he instituted the
literacy program as part of a broader
political strategy to brainwash the
people it wasn't to teach them how to
read it was to indoctrinate them into
communism guess what they were reading
in the literacy program all right it
wasn't Hayek it wasn't Adam Smith wasn't
John Locke it was communism and why
would you why wouldn't you make it one
of your first priorities to institute a
literacy program when pretty much
everybody already knows how to read it's
because he had to brainwash the people
and the brainwashing didn't even work I
visited Cuba I've talked to Cuban people
about the Castro's not
one single cuban person likes Fidel
Castro okay the only people who like
Fidel Castro are useful idiot communists
in the West specifically in the United
States specifically the future nominee
of the Democratic Party this is very
good news that bernie is backing Fidel
Castro again these kind of the more
cautious conservatives the more
risk-averse conservatives are the ones
who say this is so bad we've got a
nominee knows for the Democratic Party
who says he kind of likes Fidel Castro
it's a good thing why because I know
that the vote is nine months away but
something tells me Trump just won
Florida okay if Bernie is the Democratic
nominee he ain't gonna win Florida
there's a lot of Cubans in Miami okay
another story just came out of The Daily
Beast said in the late 1970s Bernie
Sanders defended Iran's taking of
American hostages he actually defended
through a party that he was affiliated
with in Vermont defended the Iran
Iranian seizure of Americans right now
let's play out all the scenarios right
now if if Bernie wins the nomination the
Democratic Party will be in chaos and he
will most likely lose the general
election because he's simply too radical
and his base isn't wide enough that's
one scenario second scenario if Bernie
catches momentum but loses the
Democratic nomination the Democratic
Party will be an even greater chaos and
that will certainly weaken them in the
general election the birth of the Bernie
bro stayed home in 2016 wait until 2020
all right then then the third aspect of
this beyond sort of merely partisan
considerations what helps the
Republicans what hurts the Democrats a
Trump vs. Bernie fight is maybe the
clearest choice America's ever had it's
an honest choice and it's good in
self-governing Republic's to have honest
choices you've got Trump who is a symbol
of the American original businessman and
you've got Bernie Sanders who is a
lifelong Nair do well communist
propagandist who's never held down a
real job in the private sector in his
whole life all of which means
conservatives should
be feeling the burn and by the way
Bernie Sanders is not even the most
radical candidate in the race I know he
seems like it because on the surface he
says the most radical things and he's
got the craziest-looking here and he's
like a thousand years old and he waves
his arms around all the time
Bernie may be the most radical candidate
when it comes to economics and
government but when it gets to cultural
questions which by don't forget that's
where a lot of our politics lives when
it comes to cultural questions there's
another candidate who is at least as
radical back in and it is Pete boo to
judge my least favorite candidate in the
race there was an amazing and horrifying
moment on the campaign trail for Pete
just the other day we'll get to that in
a second I want to give people a little
context though because no one knows
anything about Peabody Judge right that
is another guy who really came out of
nowhere I don't know how the oppo file
on him is it's not like Bernie Sanders
had been in politics for 50 years the
people who do jazz like is a 12 years
old himself but Buddha judges now
portraying himself as the moderate
candidate in the race he's no moderate
he's a you know he's got a nice haircut
and he's a clean-cut boy from the
Midwest and he speaks in a very balanced
way he's no moderate p-goon a judge's
father was a founding member and
president of the International Gramsci
Society for those who don't know Gramsci
is sort of little-known except among
people who spend time studying communism
Antonio Gramsci
is one of the most famous communists in
history he was a communist philosopher
in Italy he was the leader of the
Italian Communist Party he had a huge
influence on what you would call neo
Marxism so bringing Marxism from the
realm of the economic into the realm of
the cultural as well a very very
important philosopher in the history of
Marxism Buddha judges father not just
some kind of moderate Midwest guy he was
the devotee of Gramsci he was the
president and founding member of his
Society now you might say well that was
his father Pete's totally different is
Pete totally different there's a big
irony in this Democratic primary which
is that pbut a judge for a lot of his
life was a great
of Bernie Sanders pbut a judge in 2000
when he was still in high school
wrote an essay praising Bernie Sanders
and this is an important moment because
bernie is mainstream now by definition
because he'll Bernie almost won the
nomination in 2016 and he likely will
win it this year but that's only because
the Democratic Party has recently swung
very very far to the left in 2000 Bernie
Sanders was a joke he was a punchline
he was the most radical guy in the US
government and moderate Pete good old
Midwestern Pete wrote an essay in high
school
praising him people judges a smart guy
okay it's not like he was just some
dummy when he was in high school the guy
was what road Scholar Harvard educated
you can make McKinsey he's radical he's
distasteful he's dishonest but he's a
smart guy he knew what he was doing and
I think he probably knew what he was
doing even then so Buddha jej total fake
moderate actually quite a radical and
there was a disgusting and radical scene
at a peak Buddha jej rally over the
weekend tells us a lot about Pete but
more importantly cuz I actually don't
care that much about Pete doesn't look
like Pete's gonna win the nomination it
gets to a bigger topic which is our
cultural identity crisis why we've got
the rise of woke identity politics what
identity politics really means one of
Pete muda judges producers took a
question from a gay nine-year-old is
there what does that mean what what does
it mean to be a gay nine-year-old before
you've gone through puberty I couldn't
really tell you here's the question the
next question comes from Zachary aged 9
and this is a really touching question
he says thank you for being so brave
would you help me tell the world I'm gay
too
I want to be brave like you
that question tells you a whole lot
about the state of the Democratic Party
and P Buddha judges answer tells you
even more we'll get to that in a second
first I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube
you've got to head on over to Daly
wire.com look there are a lot of
different tiers of membership now you
can be a daily wire insider you can be
an insider plus where you can get a
whole Megillah and get the all-access
tear what do you get you get me at the
end replevin show the ben shapiro show
the Matt Walsh shirt you get to ask
questions in the mailbag if you're all
access you get to ask questions and
personal Q&A is you get a whole lot of
stuff and most importantly get the
leftist tears tumblr which is going to
be very important over the next nine
months until the election in November so
head on over to daily wire.com we'll be
back with a lot more
a child who has not yet gone through
puberty wants to come out as gay on a
presidential campaign stage on national
television and the Democrats cheer him
on they're so excited you hear that
we've got a fun a really touching
amazing question from a prepubescent
child who wants to make bold sexual
declarations on national television yeah
hooray
never mind that the kid almost certainly
doesn't know what gay means he
definitely doesn't know what gay means
he might have some inclination that it
refers to sexual attraction between
members of the same sex what on earth
could he possibly know about the
significance of that statement he's nine
years old most 19 year olds don't know
quite what that means people who were
struggling with their sexuality don't
know all of the implications of that she
was saying a nine-year-old does I mean
we protect kids from this kind of stuff
for a reason all right kids are too
young to understand the complexities and
consequences of sexual decisions that's
why we have an age of consent the reason
that it's illegal to sleep with a 16 or
17 year old is because we've decided as
a society that 16 and 17-year olds are
still too young to understand all of the
implications all of the consequences all
of the complexities that go along with
sexual decision-making so we protect
them from that this is why it requires
an ID if you want to go buy a Playboy
we've decided you know even if you're in
your teenage years you still are too
young we have to you have to be
protected from making sexual decisions
some of which will last your whole life
you know if you're just to get to the
age of consent thing let's say you're 15
16 years old you have a one-night stand
that one-night stand can have
psychological consequences on you for
the rest of your life and of course it
could have other consequences like STDs
and pregnancy how much more so should we
apply those kind of protections to a
nine year old prepubescent child
as we would to a 16 or 17 year old
teenager Budaj edge to his credit
seems pretty uncomfortable with this
question because he realizes how creepy
and weird this is that you've got the
whole of this Democratic crowd saying
yeah yeah nine year old make bold claims
about sex yeah we love hearing that
so Budaj edge stumbles around at first
he's a little uncomfortable answering
stammers stumbles then he decides you
know what I'm in this thing it's 2020
this is the Democratic Party I want to
be President
so he eventually just embraces it and
gives the kid a shout out Zachary if
you're here and you want to give a wave
let me know
[Applause]
love is love this is the dark side of
sentimentality and we increasingly as a
culture are giving ourselves over to
sentimentality or abandoning our use of
reason we are abandoning our logic we're
abandoning rigorous analysis and we're
just giving over to sentimentality how
you feel if it feels good do it my truth
is the only truth that matters and it's
certainly more important than the truth
that kind of sentimentality love is love
which is the mantra used to defend
redefining marriage is a ridiculous
political mantra it doesn't mean
anything because what it's saying I
guess it means something what it just
means it's ridiculous it means that all
types of love are exactly the same
that's what love is love all love is the
same this was very useful when they were
trying to redefine marriage during the
obergefell decision in other previous
legislative battles but on its face it's
absurd because not all love is the same
we know this love between love for your
spouse is a lot different than love for
your brother unless you read Slate
Magazine then maybe it's a little more
confusing love for your child is
different than love for your co-workers
love for your family right it's
different than love for your friends
even love is different depending on the
context love is a very complex thing in
this case the way we discuss love and
sex should be very different for adults
as for children
I mean imagine applying the same sort of
sexual mantras that we apply to adults
consenting adults as we do to
nine-year-old children but love is love
sentimentality sacrifices all of that on
the altar of the sexual revolution so
Pete who hesitates at first and then
they get the slogan going and then
they're all given away into this
political moment Pete calls the kid up
on stage and he gives him it
that is so typical of the modern
Democratic Party in the modern left but
which is ultimately so destructive so
let me tell you let me tell you a couple
things that might be useful the first
thing is that it won't always be easy
but that's ok because you know who you
are and that's really important because
when you know who you are you have a
center of gravity that can hold you
together when all kinds of chaos is
happening around you that's the first
thing I want you to know there it is
there it is that's the mistake you know
who you are this is maybe the key to our
sentimentality epidemic is this idea of
authenticity if you're as long as you're
authentic to yourself then you will be
firmly grounded in reality you know you
might not know anything else about the
world you might not know anything about
arithmetic or you might not know French
or you might not know history but you
know who you are and therefore we will
orient everything else to this self
knowledge except nine-year-olds don't
know who they are
most 29 year olds don't know who they
are but 9 year olds certainly don't know
who they are that's why you have
education that's why you grow up that's
why you go through your teenagers it's
why you go through puberty alright
you've got what you change during all of
these moments the idea that you are
exactly who you were when you were 9
years old is totally absurd but beyond
that sort of minor point is Pete's
bigger point which is even crazier
Pete's larger point is that who you are
is defined by the sum total of your
sexual desires it's not just Pete making
this point the whole left makes this
point that who you are is just who you
want to sleep with in this case of
sexual identity politics or in the case
of racial identity politics you could
say who you are is your skin color
that's who you are at bottom or in the
case of of gender politics similar to
sexual
politics who you are is based on your
genitals or now that we have transgender
theory now it's not based on your
genitals very very confusing all
identity politics all of it is absurd
because it mistakes part of our
identities with the whole of it or with
the essence of it in a rightly ordered
society in the traditional society our
identities are much more firmly rooted
than okay so in a rightly ordered
society our identity is rooted in okay I
Know Who I am I know Michael that's me
that's who I am I am born into a family
in a community in a country and
ultimately my identity is at bottom
religious because I am man-made in the
image of God who is identity itself very
firmly rooted okay when when God is
talking to Moses Moses says who shall I
tell people that you are God says I am
that I am which is to say I am being
itself
I am identity and you're made in my
image and if you trace your identity to
me you're gonna be pretty firmly rooted
and then we've got other identities that
come downstream of that I'm an American
I the national identity I'm a New Yorker
I was born in New York or I am I'm a
Knowles I'm born into a family that's
the traditional view okay it's a most
solid identity you can get but what
happens when you rip all of that away
when you rip you certainly rip away the
ultimate identity because people are
denying traditional religion they're
denying God they're saying okay forget
about we can't even think about bad but
they're not just getting rid of that
they're getting rid of national identity
right you've got guys like Pete Buddha
judge and Joe Biden saying on American
is whatever I say an American is people
who are foreign nationals are actually
more American than Americans right
they've got all the Democratic
candidates saying we pretty much have to
rip away our national borders take down
the wall decriminalize illegal crossings
it's a get rid of national identity how
about family identity increasingly the
state is encroaching on on the role of
the family saying families can't do
certain things families can't raise
their kids certain ways families can't
teach their kids certain things if
you're ripping away the family itself
and all of this is done
on the thesis that once you rip away all
of those your religious identity your
national identity your cultural identity
then you get the self and you will be
more firmly rooted in yourself which is
your true identity except that the
opposite happens when you rip away all
those other identities you are more
isolated from yourself than ever that's
why you have this loneliness epidemic
that's why you have all of these sorts
of crazy crises that are happening right
now
and we are having a cultural identity
crisis so the result of that is that the
supposedly moderate Democrat in the
presidential race is trotting
prepubescent kids on stage to tell them
that they are the sum total of their
sexual desires all to the raucous
applause of Democratic primary voters
that is some radical stuff before we get
onto a OCS expensive dress which is
something of a controversy even among
conservatives I want to take a question
from the live chat from JH I Michael
what do you think of the rumors that
Bloomberg wants Hillary as VP on his
ticket and the likelihood that he would
be epstein to his coronation oh man of
all the stupid political decisions you
could make I think picking Hillary
Clinton as your VP would be the top one
have you ever have you ever thought of a
more dangerous position to be in than
with Hillary just waiting for you to get
suicided at the top of the ticket I mean
even even if she weren't going to
suicide you let's let's try to be fair
for a moment that doesn't happen
typically you don't want to pick a VP
who's just single ambition in life is to
have your job and who is one heartbeat
away from your job probably not a good
idea Michael uber he's a very smart man
so I think he wouldn't make that mistake
although he's run one of the dumbest
political campaigns in recent history as
we may have time to see in a second so I
don't know maybe he'll make that mistake
in which case I'd like to say that I'm
very very sorry to hear of the imminent
suicide of Mike Bloomberg I didn't even
know he was depressed let's get on to
AOC AAS he went on the view
AOC went on the view and wore an
expensive dress not like a $10,000 dress
but addresses like maybe five hundred
bucks and she's getting a lot of flack
for it from the conservative Erika
nürnberg tweets out don't you love it
when an avowed socialist worse a five
hundred eighty dollar dress from Ricky
Freeman I mean who doesn't need a
sequined leopard dress to be an
effective congresswoman obviously
pointing out the hypocrisy AO sees this
class warrior she says everyone has too
much money and yet she's wearing an
expensive dress but then the plot
thickens because someone found out that
the dress was recently on sale for only
$280 but then the plot thickens even
more cos AOC made this kind of a vague
denial it wasn't a specific denial so I
don't believe it but she said yeah look
sometimes I rent my clothing sometimes I
get it at thrift stores so hey stop
picking on me she doesn't say anything
in particular about the dress itself
she's just making these vague comments
most of which I don't really believe
it's it's not really a denial it so much
as a dismissal now a lot of
conservatives are defending aoc they're
saying oh this is come on this is a dumb
thing to attack her for yeah politicians
were expensive clothing come on it's not
even that expensive
who doesn't have six hundred dollar
dresses yeah a lot of people don't have
six hundred ollar dresses but that's
beside the point the point is not how
much the dress cost the point is a OCS
hypocrisy okay first of all for for all
of the people that aoc constantly
invokes the marginalize the people who
don't have two nickels to rub together
five hundred eighty dollars or two
hundred eighty dollars is a lot of money
to spend on a dress but beyond that the
point is that a oh C's political
philosophy boils down to castigating
people for their wealth and she's the
one who says billionaires shouldn't
exist and if you are going to base your
whole political philosophy on
castigating people for your wealth you
need to be able to explain why you are
allowed to indulge in certain expensive
luxuries but other people are not okay I
don't I do not begrudge aoc her sequined
$600 dress but she and her fellow class
huh
need to answer this one simple question
how much money are people allowed to
have or to spend how much just give me a
number all right if you if that's your
philosophy that there's a cap and above
a certain point people are not allowed
to have the money or spend the money
then just give me a number so that we
know what we're dealing with here but
she won't answer it because the number
is always changing and the numbers
always changing because her net income
is our net wealth is always changing
same thing with Bernie Sanders
conveniently the amount of money that
you're not allowed to have her spend is
always just a little bit more money than
they have Bernie Sanders you can track
it on Twitter castigates the
millionaires and the billionaires for
his whole political career all of 2016
was about the millionaires and the
billionaires and then Bernie made a
million dollars and he could no longer
deny that he was a millionaire and do
you know it like the very day that he
became a millionaire the millionaires
were okay and it's actually the
billionaires who were the bad guys and
he stopped talking about the
millionaire's in the billionaire's it
was just the billionaires be consistent
you've got a any political view that is
playing on Envy that is castigating
whole classes of people because they
happen to have a lot of things is is bad
in and of itself but when you're
cynically moving the goal posts because
you are getting wealthier and wealthier
and wealthier and you keep hustling
based on envy that's that's even worse
than all of that
so it's cynical it's vicious it promotes
envy and I'm very pleased that AOC is
getting criticism for it it's a totally
fair attack before we go I have to bring
up these stupid billboards that Mike
Bloomberg is using you know evidence
that Bloomberg could make the horrible
political decision to pick Hillary as
his VP Bloomberg put these billboards up
in Nevada I believe if the billboards
were part of Mike's with novel wild
wacky campaign where he puts pictures of
his face on a meatball and that's
supposed to win him the presidency and
they the billboards all just made jokes
about Trump
so one said Donald Trump cheats at golf
Mike Bloomberg doesn't the other one
said Donald Trump's
all fell over because a port a part of
the border fence collapsed like a little
portion of it and they're fixing it now
and the third one is my favorite Donald
Trump eats bird steak Mike Bloomberg
likes his medium-rare yeah that's how
you're going to appeal to the the people
and say you're gonna make yourself a man
of the people
is make fun of the president for eating
his food in a way that most people eat
their food frankly and and then say that
you have a much more refined palate even
though most people don't eat their food
that way doesn't work doesn't work for
two reasons I mean someday poli-sci
classes are going to teach full
semesters on Mike Bloomberg's campaign
as evidence of what not to do the first
reason this doesn't work Bloomberg gives
Trump top billing in all of the signs
its Donald Trump does this Donald Trump
doesn't do this and then Mike Bloomberg
very tiny at the bottom but it's
actually just an ad for Donald Trump
okay the only thing worse than being
talked about is not being talked about
and if you're making your opponent the
focus of everything you're losing this
is why politicians don't name their
opponents oh I say what my opponent said
was blah blah blah
because they don't want to give the
opponent free press but that's what Mike
Bloomberg is doing you spend a half a
billion dollars to give Donald Trump
more press Donald Trump who's got more
publicity maybe than anyone who has ever
lived other than Alexander the Great
you know a few other people the second
problem here is it's just incredibly
condescending they say oh you you
overcook your steak first of all most
people don't get to eat steak that much
just generally speaking a steak is
expensive but when people do at stake I
would wager that the majority of people
eat their steak medium to more cooked
now I don't because I come from the same
place as Mike Bloomberg does in New York
so in New York we like to eat our steak
where it's barely cooked at all it's
mooing right it's completely red if not
black and blue but for most of the
country I don't think that's the case
when I travel around a lot of different
places a lot of places won't even let
you order something rare or you know
totally rare
so Bloomberg is saying I'm so much
better than you I've got so much better
taste not a good way to appeal to voters
you know Donald Trump is able to make
sort of the opposite appeal he says he
loves fast food and he actually does
love fast food he's got a long record of
this but the Bloomberg campaign it's
schizophrenic on this the other day they
tweeted and said Mike Bloomberg loves
eating at Subway no he does and where
he's never eaten at Subway
they're trying to pretend this and then
on the other end they're saying oh but
he only it's a steak medium-rare he only
he's a tough with foie gras he would
never eat that gruel like president
Trump and overcook it ooh not not a good
way to win polls show a drop in
likability after that debate that took
place the one debate that he was in
where he just absolutely got torn limb
from limb and so it would seem like it's
Bernie's game this is risky we could
have a socialist as the president but I
think it's a risk that conservatives
should cheer on because it's honest and
I think it gives us the best chance of
winning every state plus Greenland okay
that's our show
I'm Michael Knowles's the Michael Nolt
show come on back tomorrow see that
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
whanau ski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael Knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation